hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
miguel de una muno in his book tragic
sense of life begins
by considering the origins
of philosophies and i'm deliberately
putting that
in the plural because he will talk about
philosophy
as a singular but it's not a
single thing that we can refer to
and make absolute claims about although
that is part of the
history of philosophy people indeed
doing that like
kant who he brings up in the very first
chapter
and what we need to understand from the
start is that philosophy
refers to multiple matters it's not just
a single thing that you can wrap your
head around provide a definition of
he considers a few people's definitions
like cicero's
uh in in this work and then says well
that that works for
you know a certain kind of
philosophizing and we need to understand
that philosophy is at all times
a human activity and a human
product and when we think about what
philosophy means this is not something
that he's directly saying
here in the text but i think he's
presupposing this there is the
the action or acts of engaging in
philosophy
there is all the other things that are
coming
from our background and our desires that
are feeding into philosophy there are
sort of
ends that we're aiming at there is the
history of all sorts of philosophical
texts that are written down which we can
pick up
and and start reading and in a certain
way connect with people
in ancient or medieval or early modern
times
cross cultures there's all these
different things
and then there are all sorts of
philosophical systems or
approaches and quite often people want
to
narrow what philosophy is so as to make
it much more
easy to teach and easy for them to
understand but unemuno
is coming at this from a different
perspective which says there are
philosophies
and we can look into them and we can
take on parts of them if we want to we
can take on
entire systems and say that's what i'm
going to be
and we can also think about our own
activity we can engage in some
reflection
about what we're doing and so
he is going to talk about the concrete
human being and when we say concrete we
you know another great translation the
very title of the first chapter
the man of flesh and bone the human
being
who actually exists who has
what the existentialist would later call
facticity
who is born in a certain time who
has an age a gender a
set of predilections for some things and
against other things
and he goes on and he says
here we go the person of flesh and bone
the person who was born
suffers dies above all who dies the
person who eats and drinks and plays and
sleeps and thinks and will
the person who has seen and heard the
the brother
the sibling the real brother and he says
there's another thing which is also
called
humanity the subject of all sorts of
ideas the
zone politicon the political animal of
aristotle the social contractor of
rousseau
the homo economicus of the manchester
school
the homo sapiens of linnaeus or if you
like the vertical
animal and then he says this is really a
great line
a man of neither here nor there neither
of this age nor of another who has
neither sex nor country
who is in brief merely an idea
that is to say a no man and a lot of
people philosophize as if they are
no man nobody right the the nobody
he's referring to of the the odyssey
which was a lie when odysseus told it
right um and he says that the person
that we have to do with is the person of
flesh and bone
i you reader of mine the other person
over there and all who walk solidly on
the earth
and he tells us this is very interesting
this concrete person
is at the same time the subject
and the supreme object of philosophy
whether self-styled philosophers like it
or not
so that is a really important point
it's not just rhetoric here of trying to
you know make a nice sentence
we are the subject we are the
the one who engages in philosophy
and we have to take account of the fact
that there wouldn't be any philosophy
were it not for concrete human beings
philosophy is not done by some ideal
human being as a matter of fact if you
think about like plato's forms
right and you've got this ideal human
that perhaps we're all copies of you can
ask yourself what is that what does that
guy do
you know or we could just well make it a
woman what does that person do
right they they don't do anything that
that we engage in
in real life like you know eating and
drinking
and you know being attracted to people
and fighting with them
and you know all those sorts of things
earning a living he doesn't have to
enter a living he's in the world of the
forms
maybe he philosophizes well if he does
he hasn't produced any that we know of
right plato never says any peep about
him and so we can say something similar
about philosophy
in general it is produced by actual
living
human beings who are at subjects and
that's not just
famous people like schopenhauer or kant
that's you and me as well and we are the
supreme
object of philosophy as well
philosophy also touches on other things
the laws of thought the laws of thought
of who
human beings philosophy touches on the
cosmos the cosmos for who
human beings right so whether we're
doing
ethical philosophy or political
philosophy or we're doing other things
like epistemology and metaphysics and
logic
we're dealing with human beings so this
is a very important point that he makes
he also tells us a few other things that
are fleshing this
out he he tells us that we've made a
mistake
quite often in assuming that
the what's really distinctive about us
is
reasoning rationality and he he says
here we go this is some some wonderful
lines in here
says um the human is said to be a
reasoning animal i do not know
why he has not also been defined as an
affective or
feeling animal now you could say well
i know why because aristotle
or plato or the stoics or pick whoever
you like in western philosophy
looked at human beings and they saw that
we had our feelings in common with the
animals our affective
side what aristotle calls the orec the
desirous
or affective part we have that in common
with you know lynxes
and earthworms and pick whatever you
like we even have some things in common
with
plants you know we engage in respiration
and
reproduction and you know some sort of
growth and digestion and
when a mortal goes out and he says yes
but he says perhaps what differentiates
us from other animals is
actually feeling rather than reason
depends on how we're going to understand
these
things and he's got a sort of throwaway
line here more often
i have seen a cat reason than laugh or
weep perhaps it weeps or laughs inwardly
but then perhaps also inwardly the crab
resolves equations of the second degree
and the idea is that the human being
our feelings are different than those of
other animals
they are also analogous you know when
the cat gets angry
uh or you know to to use the song
uh chorus when the dog bites when the
bee stings right
from uh that that sound of music song
um there's something like anger going on
there but it's not quite exactly the
same as human anger and perhaps
sadness isn't the same and perhaps even
joy isn't the same
why should that not be equally
distinctive
of human beings we are not only a
reasoning animal but an
affective animal he also tells us now
here we come back to the
very important point for philosophy
feeling is not just an
output or a consequence or a result
of taking philosophical positions
feeling is what drives it feeling
is a cause he gives
an example here he says philosophy
answers to our need of forming a
complete and unitary
conception of the world and life and as
a result of this conception a feeling
which gives birth to an inward attitude
and even to outward action but the fact
is that this feeling instead of being a
consequence of this conception
is a cause of it our philosophy that is
our mode of understanding or not
understanding the world in life
springs from our feeling towards life
itself something what we might call a
fundamental mood
right life like everything effective has
roots in subconsciousness perhaps even
in
unconsciousness so we're not really
entirely aware of why we philosophize in
the way that we do
he goes on and he says it's not our
ideas that make us optimists or
pessimists
it's our optimism or pessimism of
physiological or perhaps
pathological origin as much the one as
the other that makes
our ideas and so what we have here is
similar to
for example nietzsche as saying that you
know philosophy
the origins of it really lie in
biography in in the person
who is doing the philosophy and what
they're driven by what they desire
what they're averse to what their
fundamental mood
inhabiting their their world is
he also goes on and this is in chapter
two
he's got a very interesting point here
when he's talking about what it means to
be a rational animal
he tells us that philosophy is a product
of the humanity of each philosopher
and each philosopher is a man of flesh
and bone okay so far so good
what's he adding here there's something
new
a person who addresses himself to other
men of flesh and bone
like himself let him do what he will he
philosophizes not with the reason only
but with the will with the feelings with
the flesh and with the bones with the
whole
soul and the whole body it is the person
who philosophizes so we philosophize not
just as these isolated
monads you know working out our own
dynamics or
affectivities we're also doing it in
relation to other people
which means that they have an influence
on us and we have an influence on them
and we're not just trying to reach
ourselves but also to reach them
and this is true even for somebody like
descartes you know
if you think about his his famous
suspension
of belief and the methodological doubt
where perhaps there's no other being in
the universe except this evil demon or
maybe god or
stuff like that he is not saying that
because he really 100
believes that that is getting him to a
place where he can talk to other human
beings
about how they ought to use their minds
so these are some very important points
we can also talk about how unemuno
thinks of the activities
or products of philosophy i've already
mentioned that
quoting that thing that he thinks that
philosophy aims at providing us with a
complete and unitary conception of the
world
and of life this does not mean that we
ever
truly attain that in part because the
world you know is much vaster than us
and so is
the life that we're living but that's
what it's aiming at
he also calls it a little bit later a
work of integration
and synthesis that's another way of
talking about how we get to
this more or less complete viewpoint
he's got he's got another really great
discussion in chapter two
about the origins of philosophy
as well he says in the starting point of
philosophy the real starting point which
is not theoretical
it's actually practical there is a
wherefore the philosopher philosophizes
for something more
than for the sake of philosophizing
philosophy is not a self-contained
discipline it's done for the sake
of and driven by something other than
just the activity
of philosophizing it's always
practical to some degree and
he goes on and he says as the
philosopher is a person before they're a
philosopher
you have to live before you can
philosophize and in fact
you philosophize in order to live
usually one philosophizes either in
order to resign oneself to life or seek
some finality
in it or distract oneself and forget
one's griefs or for pastime
and amusement and we could go on and on
and on with all the other
reasons why people engage in philosophy
which could just also be inertia you
know
i've been doing philosophy now i mean
myself i've been studying philosophy
professionally for 30 years
and teaching it for over 20
and you know if somebody were to ask me
why do you do it
i could you know quite reasonably say
you know i don't know anymore
i just keep on doing it out of inertia
and i enjoy what i do
so that's not actually the case but that
would be an interesting
response would it not so philosophy is
always guided by some sort of wherefore
understanding that wherefore helps us to
understand that philosophy
and these all tie in together the last
thing i need to point out is that una
muno rejects what he calls pedentry
and truth for truth's sake and a kind of
fake
history of systems this is a great line
here he says
in most of the histories of philosophy
that i know and this is actually still
the case
in large part today except for those
that swing way over to the other extreme
and then commit the genetic fallacy by
attributing everything
to you know where the philosopher came
from or you know what his or her
preoccupations were
he says philosophical systems are
presented to us as if growing
out of one another spontaneously and
their authors the philosophers appear as
mere pretexts
just sort of like you know they're the
ones who happen to be there to think
these thoughts at the time
the inner biography of the philosophers
of the people who philosophized occupies
a secondary place
but it's precisely this inner biography
that explains for us
most things that's a good point right
there
and he rejects any sort of you know
truncation
of philosophy any shortening of it he's
got a great discussion here
about professional philosophers he says
there are in fact people who appear to
think only with the brain or whatever
may be the specific thinking or
organ well others think with all the
body all the soul with the blood the
marrow of the bones the heart the lungs
the belly the life
and he says the people who think only
with the brain develop into definition
mongers isn't that a great catchphrase
they're definition mongers
i think they would probably also include
a lot of the actually
guys and you know many other people who
are essentially parents
and don't realize that they are that
case he says they become the
professionals of thought
and do you know what a professional is
do you know what the product of
differentiation of labor
is he says um you know they're like
professional boxers
they're really good at what they do but
they're not good at other things
he says if a philosopher is not a man he
is anything but a philosopher
he is above all a pendant and a pedant
is a caricature of a man
the cultivation of any branch of science
maybe a work of differentiate
differentiated specialization and even
so only within narrow limits and
restrictions
but philosophy like poetry
is a work of integration and synthesis
or else it is merely
pseudo-philosophical erudition so he's
rejecting
a viewpoint on how to do philosophy
and activities of philosophy that are
far too myopic and truncated
he's also rejecting histories
and systematizations of philosophy
as such that ignore the living concrete
element of human beings
within philosophy so this gives you an
idea
of where unemuno is coming from this is
probably
something that that you have to get down
and probably buy into in order to
appreciate
what else is going on in his book
you